it's a new novel taking us back in time
to an often forgotten disaster at Sea in
September of 1934 the luxury Cruise
liner Morrow Castle caught fire and ran
aground near Asbury Park New Jersey as
it returned from Cuba more than 130
passengers and crew were lost the
Shipwreck is the backdrop for New York
Times best-selling author Chanel
Clayton's new novel The Cuban Eris
Manuel borgas sat down with her to
discuss her latest work
since the Titanic nerd disaster of the
sea has so shocked the world as the
tragedy of the American luxury liner
marrow Castle so tell us about the moro
Castle it was a luxury cruise ship it
sailed on a round-trip Voyage from New
York to Havana and when prohibition was
going on it was really an opportunity
for people to you know drink and party
and basically kind of escape the the
Great Depression and all the trials and
tribulations that were going on in the
country at that time but the moro Castle
turned into a tribulation itself on
September 7 1934 its Captain died
suddenly the next day a fire broke out
on the ship during a vicious storm as it
approached New Jersey these aerial
pictures share the vessel in the grip of
the flames and looking down on the liner
imagination can visualize the gospel
seen on board more than 130 Souls were
lost the ship's burning Hull later
drifted ashore at Asbury Park where
stuck in the sand for more than six
months it became a tourist attraction of
sorts before being towed away there was
a lot of controversy surrounding the
origins of the fire whether it was arson
if it had been sabotaged and to this day
you know despite all the investigations
that have happened there's not really a
clear understanding of necessarily what
happened to the ship mystery is
ingrained in author Chanel Clayton's
latest novel The Cuban heiress the title
a reference to one character in the book
the other is a woman seeking Revenge
both fictional passengers on the moro
Castle I've just found that I have a
passion for writing about women's lives
and history and looking at how kind of
the personal and the political intersect
it's a passion that has gained Clayton
Acclaim in the historical fiction genre
many of her novels are inspired by her
own Cuban Heritage her family fled Cuba
in 1967 after the Communist Revolution
my grandparents lived with us I spoke
Spanish and really grew up on their
stories and their memories of home and
it was so important to them to pass that
on to me and also I think to keep the
culture alive to honor the history and
and Heritage we interviewed Clayton at
the University of Miami's Cuban Heritage
collection which bills itself as the
largest collection of materials about
Cuba outside the island nation so much
life in these shelves her eyes lit up
walking through these archives as if the
inspiration for her next novel is hidden
in here somewhere but this is also
deeply personal does it help connect you
to to that past absolutely it's such an
important thing when you're an Excel
community and you don't have maybe that
tangible connection to the land of your
ancestors to have organizations like
this that have taken on this really
sacred Duty I think of preserving
history and and passing it along
passing it along is something Clayton
hopes to do too my whole family is
really from Spain but okay
and she finds when at book signings like
this one in Miami it's my pleasure
some fans of her work are also eager to
share their stories of fleeing Cuba they
don't know when they're going to return
and the first time I did the reading
years ago a woman in the audience
started crying because it resonated with
her and that was her experience among
the collection we found articles about
the moral Castle in a Cuban magazine why
is it important to revisit history I
think so much of the past informs the
present you know we kind of have to
understand where we came from to
understand where we're going and I think
it also can provide Solace and it can
provide a sense of strength in in
dealing with things in the present for
CBS Saturday morning Manuel bojorquez
Miami